michigan um
has approved an av-only highway
what is the um what is the nature of
that corridor
and is that material for what the av
industry is doing the autonomous vehicle
industry is doing
and you see that as the future of this
i'm not familiar with what michigan is
doing specifically
i think that for at least the medium
term at least the next 10 or 15 years
you generally shouldn't make a startup
that depends
on government building expensive
infrastructure
and so i believe it's like you we're
going to be in the world
immersed in human driven cars for a very
long time
is ai the way to go about
building this rule set in software and
just
plugging in all of the inputs all of
historical inputs
so you have all the times it's been
disengaged right all the times
autonomy has been disengaged all the
times there's been
accidents documented all the gps data
every videotape of every accident
all just put into an ai that says go
and you know protect the driver at all
cost
or is this going to be more verticalized
and narrow ai or narrow machine learning
you know we're going to really work on
this in sort of segments um and then how
do you how is
the the model shaping up in that regard
so a ai is a really big term uh the way
we approach it is like you're going to
make a model
and you make a model to answer a very
particular question
like where are the things i'm going to
collide with where are
where is paint on the road what is the
sky versus
other things we should ignore and then
you can break that question down into
what are all the ways we can analyze the
data to figure out what are
you know what are the axes along which
that is important
so if i were to want to say all the
things i can collide with i could start
with a very simple thing to say okay
well
i could have obstacles colliding with me
from all
different angles like let's say i'm
going to do a clock face i have my 12
o'clock i want to clock on two of them
i could have different colors i could
have different sizes and out of that you
build axes
for what you want the system to detect
and so when we think about model
building it's very much an engineering
process
to say well first you have to be very
specific about what you want
the model to what question you want to
answer you have to be
very specific about the domain like what
are all the types of inputs
and then out of that we go into the
world because we have cameras on cars
and we have a fleet
and we look for those situations to
occur naturally in the world
and then you can iterate on that you can
say okay well we had two scenarios that
we thought were the same that gave us a
different answer
so now you put that back into a creative
process that says
okay what axes did we miss so that we
can make
a new training dataset and so
and out of that you also get things like
holes like what combinations of the
world haven't i seen
and then you can pull that in from your
fleet so when i think about it it's like
the ai or the neural network itself
yeah that's how you execute it but all
the engineering goes into
the process that actually got you that
data
and how much human knowledge can you
encode
into that system and what is your
process for detecting gaps